she was my security blanket she lived
with me we did everything together
and I feel like there's a part of me
that needed to grow without her Kylie
Jenner getting candid on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians opening up about how she
felt about losing her best friend Jordan
woods sometimes people are there for
certain reasons at certain times in your
life and then not there for others yeah
obviously I love her right now she's
kind of doing her thing I'm doing my
thing so I'm kind of just I'm happy
Jordan and Kylie had a falling out after
the 22 year old hooked up with Khloe
Kardashian's ex Tristan Thompson at a
party in February you know things happen
and of course I'm sorry and apologetic
as much as I can be et has spoken with
Jordan a couple times since it all went
down and she seems focused on leaving
the past in the past
she and Kylie haven't been seen together
since the scandal life moves on money
doesn't stop world doesn't stop and
hopefully everyone of course the
incident marked the second time Tristan
had publicly cheated on the mother of
his one-year-old daughter true I'm
feeling better and better with every day
I feel more at peace knowing that
Kylie's in such a good headspace right
now everything's hooked up in Ferg
reason I feel like this is like the
season to filter through the [ __ ]
mm-hmm
you know I don't have a strong and loyal
Will Survive yeah and in the episode
Chloe revealed she was in therapy with
Tristan I desire to have a good
coexisting relationship with him but
like I can't see myself ever being able
to trust him he said I know you and your
family made this a big media thing
and like would you think I would want
this out there not in a million years
which you have wanted this public when
et caught up with Chloe in June she said
she was feeling good and focusing on
family I'm in a good place but I think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever mission and I always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people while the world is changing
around us we should adapt to that too
but always remember to be kind and just
courteous of what's happening around you
too so I don't ever want that to change
are you dating no I'm not dating right
now I just I'm really just enjoying my
life and my time with my baby and family
if you think about it in the future do
you know what kind of guy you would want
down the road I've never really put that
much pressure on dating I'm just you
know whoever you are in a room with that
you connect with and there's chemistry
then that's you should date but I'm just
not even in that headspace but you never
know what will happen